Someone who's disrespected Khabib's
father who passed away disrespected him
was talking about his wife. What does
Khabib say? Khabib can use that to his
advantage. If he was someone look how
beautiful in his character and imagine
how the prophet would have been.
Islam is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation, you will
inshallah be reaping the reward. Click
the link and donate what you can.
>> Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
Subhan Allah. This was a talk in New
York uh of Khabib and on stage he said
something a message that he sent to
Conor McGregor. Now when you look at
Conor McGregor and Khabib, you see a
stark difference of course in many ways.
Not that one is obviously somebody who
disbelieves in Allah and his messenger
etc. But something more profound than
that because there's a lot of people who
believe in Allah but have the same
disgusting attitude, arrogancy etc. like
Connor. What makes a believer different
is his character. That's what the
prophet peace be upon him said. I came
for nothing but to perfect good
character, good manners etiquette. The
prophetam's manners, his truthfulness,
the way he carried himself and lived
living, walking, talking Islam is what
is what a true believer is. But subhan
Allah, that's the stuff difference.
Here's here's the message Khabib had
forg.
And let's see what lessons we can learn.
>> I don't want to mention his name.
>> This is punishment. everything that we
didn't all talk
alcohol g drugs everything this is this
is punishment it's beginning or little
but you know it's uh what most beautiful
part of this Allah always give for us
doesn't matter anybody everybody to
chance come back always they have always
in this world chance to come back you
know and
And this is most beautiful things
doesn't matter how you Allah going to
give you chance to publish I have chosen
[Applause]
because
know him if he going to change he can
change with him so many other lives too
>> and that's why I wish him if he change
if you're not going to change
he will be
almost I talk about all the time.
>> He's right.
>> Okay. Subhan Allah. Look how amazing
that is. Someone who's disrespected
Khabib's father who passed away
disrespected him was talking about his
wife. They're trying to disrespect him
with the alcohol thing etc. Look how
Allah emulated Connor and Allah will
carry on emiliating those who oppose
Allah and his messenger or try to mock
it. So much so Conor McGregor has become
a farright kind of thug and subhan look
at now what's his accusation that's
coming about him of sexual assault rape.
Yes being assault and he lost the case
as well. Subhan Allah. Yes. So you can
see and guess what what does Khabib say?
Khabib can use that to his advantage if
he was someone look how beautiful in his
characters and imagine how the prophet
would have been. You saw his attitude,
how Kabib was with his honor, dignity,
the way he carries him, how humble he
is. This is Islam. This is what you
called Islamist. Subhan Allah. Yeah. And
not only that, Subhan Allah, he could
have easily used that against him. He
could have come and say, "Hah, look at
Connor. Look what happened." He rather
use what happened to Connor to tell him
it is not late for you to turn back to
God, to Allah. And on top of that, look
how deep Khib is thinking. He's saying
if you do this, so many other people
will come to Islam. you will get the
reward of following the one true
religion Islam. Alhamdulillah. Just
imagine, look how gracious Hhabib is.
And he's saying, "Subhan Allah, if you
don't, Allah's punishment is severe. He
will punish you more." All look at this.
After everything he's done, which shows
it is for the sake of Allah. Like Ali
Radan, the warrior, when he was fighting
one of the pagan Arabs in war and he was
about to execute him, the man spat on
Ali's face and he was about to strike
him and he held himself and said, "I'm
not going to kill you." And the man was
begging to be killed. kill me. He said,
"If I was to do it, I fear that I would
have sent that last strike to end you
for my ns cuz you spat in my face.
Because I fear that I'm going to not do
that." Subhan Allah, brothers and
sisters. Every action is based on his
intentions. Subhan Allah. You can see,
brothers and sisters, how Allahh has
humiliated McGregor in all a subhan
ways. And subhan Allah, you can see
clearly
how he's honored and loved by the
people. Subhan Allah. And believe me
guys, only in the remembrance of Allah
do hearts find peace. And if you forget
his remeance, you will live a depressed
life. And may Allah bless and keep
preserve inshallah. May Allah bless him
inshallah. Subhan Allah. And this is
what the believers do. Subhan brothers
and sisters. That's all I had to say. I
wanted to share this beautiful moment
with you guys. Inshallah. May Allah make
us amongst those have a great character
that we can represent Islam in the best
way possible. Till next time.
Send this video to McGregor. I don't
know. I don't care if he sees it or not.
It's just I hope he saw the message of
Khabib which is most importantly. Till
next time. Goodbye.